welcome to you off to the meeting of
this council
and may i first of all remind you of
some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the ipswich
town football club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
can i ask that you switch off all mobile
phones or turn them to silent please
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
council members of the public and the
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
thank you
can i move to the agenda please
item one
apologies for absence
thank you chair
apologies have been received from
councillors mentally barrett carpendale
gold grandin holt
huron elvazi
norman mabry
parker
ward
jan osborne and councillor heartache
councillors if you haven't already done
so please could you mark yourself as
present in the modern.gov app please
yeah
thank you for that
item two declarations of interest by
councillors
are there any declarations of interest
thank you
and i turn to item three bc 21 stroke 19
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 21st of september
2021 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
then could i have a proposal please
thank you councillorathe
uh could i have a second please
thank you sue ayers councillor suez
thank you
i will now ask the senior government
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members the vote is now
in progress on your modern.gov app
please scroll down to the blue line
i'm an approve i'm just logged into the
um the previous meeting so i'll catch up
eventually
thank you councillor beer may i take
your vote verbally please
that's unanimous that's 19 votes for
um mr chairman i'm proud of what i can
hardly hear you can you get nearer to
the maui
thank you i'll move it to one side
sorry peter
um
where were we oh yeah item four
announcements from the chairman and
leader
bc 21 stroke 20.
i refer to the paper bc 2120 for noting
but i'd just like to say that
i was extremely uh pleased at being at
the meeting and would like to
congratulate all the officers that took
part in the local energy
showcase it was a great uh it was a
great event and thank you all for doing
being there and putting it on thank you
councillor ward
has pre-recorded his leaders
announcements
as he is not able to be here
and we will now play that recording
good evening everyone unfortunately i
can't be with you all in person this
evening as i have a very bad cold and
cough
it is definitely nothing more
i have done two lateral flow tests and
one pcr test and all were negative
this is the first of additional council
meetings designed to enable members to
participate in debates on a range of
topics
we are reinstating cabinet member
reports we have the first two this month
we are introducing debates on current
live issues and topics of interest as an
alternative to member briefings which
are not always well attended
this evening we will be discussing the
current status of covered recovery in
weber
covering business confidence
its lingering impact and ongoing changes
to the behaviour of our residents
finally we will also be having a series
of location reports from different parts
of the district
there will be a rolling program running
from east to west and this will start
next year
i hope you will value these themes and
please feedback any comments or
suggestions you may have
last week an all-member briefing from
the economic development team was held
this was excellent and highlighted the
huge amount of activity and projects
delivered in the district
our approach to supporting innovation is
getting recognition nationally and we
are definitely having an impact on
stimulating the post code economy and
delivering jobs
yesterday mark the start of our new
in-house public realm service
15 new members of staff arrived at the
stone market depot and councillor dawson
was there to welcome them alongside our
answers
i'd like to thank our project team for
all their hard work over the past 12
months to make this such a success
as announced at the weekend the
government has agreed to suffer its
request to be designated a covered
enhanced response area
we will get extra resources to increase
vaccinations
and provide other support
increasing booster vaccinations and the
vaccination rate for 12 to 15 year olds
are the main priorities
a walk-in service at hadley church on
saturday was very successful with 2030
people getting a jab
you will also have been aware of the
recent exhibitions of plans for bellevue
park in sudbury
i want to thank the officers who were
present for giving their time
particularly on the saturday and to all
the councillors who also visited and
spoke to many of the public there
feedback regarding the churchill
development was has to be expected mixed
not totally dominated by the proposal
plans to regenerate the park
the feedback on our new entrance was in
contrast overwhelmingly in favor of the
plans praising the design thoroughness
and quality of the visual elements
the major concerns were over access
across a busy junction but we will
address this with suffolk county council
highways
ensure that safe crossings from the town
will be provided
there were some useful suggestions for
further improvements and conversations
with skatepark users were also very
informative i just want to note one
particular comment we received that
some of the more vocal groups in the
press do not speak for all of sudbury
and cornard
we shouldn't lose sight of it that when
assessing particularly what is said
online and the term that is used by
contributors there
which brings me on to my next item
i would like to spend a few minutes
reflecting on the tragic murder of sir
david amos following five years on from
that of joe cox with some of the
subsequent commentary regarding the
increasing lack of tolerance and
coarsening of the political climate that
we are experiencing now primarily
resulting from the lawless domain that
social media has become
as the data may as a daily mirror
recently commented there is an ugliness
affecting public discourse
this is more than the lazy destructive
cynicism about politics that arguably
has been growing for a few decades which
is fueled by entertainers out for a
cheap laugh
we are increasingly living in an
orwellian world where facts are regarded
as lies and lies are accepted as facts
the anti-vaxx campaigns are just the
latest sinister manifestation of this
we're having to curb an environment in
which politicians are being disbelieved
vilified and abused to an extent where
we are almost regarded as being
sub-human and therefore threats and
attacks can be justified
female politicians fare even worse with
the additional vile misogyny that they
receive
this applies to all levels of democracy
and councillors up and down the country
are experiencing similar abuse to mps
this is a real threat to representative
democracy because those who would wish
to stand will increasingly decide that
the cost is too great
if there is a lack of candidates if
there is contempt for the system and the
system fails then there will be a vacuum
that vacuum will will be filled with
something very ugly indeed
clearly there is a lot for police in the
social media companies to do to stop
this and prosecute offenders vigorously
at the moment they're all failing
dismally
however there is also a role for
councillors to play too
we must challenge inappropriate comments
from our residents and get them to
understand what is and is not acceptable
the counselors at every tier of local
government but also but must also be
very careful what we say in public
taking particular care about what we say
about each other and other authorities
mindful of how careless words can
inflame the mob
i won't say any more and i won't go into
specific events in weber which i'm sure
you will realize are the back or indeed
front of my mind
but please let's all make every effort
to help our residents engage in robust
lively but mature debate without rancor
and as for those who do not watch for
this
well they must be shunned and we must
not give them any support or
encouragement
thank you everyone
thank you
is it possible to have a printed copy of
that statement
um because it was difficult to follow up
because it kept going in and out which i
can understand
but um cornard was mentioned in other
places and i'd like to take my time and
go through it so could i possibly have a
printed copy yes sir thank you
that is agreed thank you
i'd like now to turn to item five uh to
receive notifications on petitions in
accordance with the council
procedure rules
john
thank you chair
please be advised that we've received
the following validated petition
233 valid signatures regarding planning
application dc slash 21-03644
[Music]
in ballingdon sudbury
this petition will be dealt with through
the usual planning processes
thank you
thank you john
item six
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedure rules
i would very much like to
welcome uh thomas morelli to this
meeting
mr murali
please can you ask your question to
councillor alistair mccall
cabinet member for customers in the
absence of council award
thank you
sir uh councillor mccror
um
councillor john ward has on several
recent occasions
sought to draw a distinction between the
physical presence of baber and sudbury
being referred to as a access point and
as an advice center with the latter
being something
baba has apparently never run in any of
its face-to-face locations
so
can council award in his absence
councilman mccraw
therefore please explain why the babel
website referred to its location in
sudbury as the sudbury advice centre
until at least november of 2016.
thank you very much for your question mr
morelli
uh
i answer with the words of council award
but i'll paraphrase accordingly uh the
reason the council award felt it was
important to make the distinction
between access and advice is that the
customer services provision we offer is
focused on providing face-to-face
supported access to council services and
wherever possible resolving that inquiry
at the first point of contact the word
access reflects similar language used
across several different councils and
best describes service provision offered
council award appreciates the language
may have changed since we looked at our
wider public access strategy back in
2016 to recognize that there are other
advice-led services such as citizens
advice where residents can access advice
on a wide variety of topics not just
council-led services
it's important to acknowledge that our
residents needs change over time
and that many people wish to access our
services in different ways such as
online or via telephone
however we understand that some of our
residents still prefer to contact us via
face to face which is why we offer
several in-person services to allow them
to do so
in addition to our access point at
sudbury library we've also resumed our
pop-ups in hadley and shortly
at present we are seeing approximately
10 people at the sudbury access point
per day and that's since april
we have two officers based there so this
equates to five visits per officer per
day which we feel is sufficient coverage
i do have some statistics on the
proportion of internet non-users should
you wish
um
mr morelli have your supplementary
question
it must relate
directly to his your original question
yes i do um
so um
i'll i'll ask it to councillor mccror um
i appreciate you man i'll be able to
answer it given he's not counsel john
ward but obviously if the answer needs
to be provided outside the meeting
that's fine um so
given that
when all when
the singular unified access point was
present in the town hall
residents could go in and inquire about
a town council service a district
council service or a county council
service and given that this
uh integration was something that babe
has previously highlighted on its
website um
does council award or uh council macro
crawl
agree that this
has now been lost and uh
does he feel that this has had any
negative effect on the residents of
sudbury
okay if i may reply um
in terms of the services and the access
necessary for the services provided by
the town council
and those supplied by the district
council
they would in fact be different and
their requirements would be somewhat
different
the two buildings as it happens are not
very far apart and it would be perfectly
possible to make
an access on the same day to both
locations i don't possess any figures
for access to sudbury town hall
that's not fundamentally
our business
the nature of our contract with
sudbury town hall
changed as circumstances have done
i i did mention that we have made
changes and continue to make changes in
our access to services
we're trying to provide appropriate
services for the ways in which customers
contact us i've mentioned the pop-up
services in shortly and hadley and we're
hoping to gain to offer places
for people to gain self-service support
we also have a telephone point which is
uh in sudbury customers can contact us
on days we're not there
we also have an ipad
available for anybody whilst sudbury
library is open customers again can
not expression i was going to use
self-service as they wish
we've also
launched very recently our ipad lending
scheme with the libraries so that
customers can loan
a wi-fi enabled tablet this will cost
them no extra money it's all ready to
use to help them access online services
at home
and as i've said the level of service we
are
receiving 10 customers per day
two offices two days a week means five
officers
work per day and we believe that is
sufficient
thank you
council mccraw thank you
mr morelli for your question
i'd now like to move on to item seven
questions by council in accordance with
council procedurals
and uh
councillor dawson please would you ask
your question to councillor busby
cabinet member for assets and
investments
to cancer busby uh please could you
provide a breakdown summary of the full
annual running costs
since vacating corpse lane development
2017
up to the development date expected um
spring 2022
to include all the costs including
maintenance insurance etc the security
and for clarification
what were the original estimated costs
for development of corks lane and the
profits at 217
and what are the recalculated
development costs of spring 2022
your question
the total cost for repairs maintenance
and security at the former headquarters
site in hadley from 2017
to the end of this financial year are
anticipated to be 500 000 pounds
this is against budgeted costs of 342
000
the original cost for de development
were anticipated to be 12.9 million
delivering a net receipt to the council
of 865 000 pounds with a total of 1.4
million being delivered back to the
public purse
she includes the net receipt loan
interest paid to the councils from the
growth company taxes
planning and building control income
full details of which are set out in the
confidential council report for descent
from december 2018 which can be sent to
you if you wish
the development costs are currently
anticipated to be circa 13 million
with a similar level of return being
anticipated with a net receipt of nine
hundred
whilst there have been delays with
deliberating this complex site
the works are currently being tended and
we anticipate that work will start on
site early next year
thank you council buzzfeed can i just
clarify the position of sitting or
standing i'm quite happy that
members sit if they so wish
thank you
um
councillor dawson have you a
supplementary um i have yes
well taking into account the development
costs
um you know which please confirm
uh in my understanding this building
costs have significantly risen from 18
to 35 in the building industry and
that's right across the board
my concern now is our original estimate
profit is now not a viable
financial proposition for our
stakeholders
and i believe uh that really you ought
to confirm perhaps if you're ensure this
comes back to the cabinet
to be discussed and to reconsider that
formal business case particularly if
you're saying the costs have gone up
from 12.9 to 13 million and that doesn't
really marry up with
price increases for all the
items that will be required to develop
this site
so will you consider
or take it on that you will bring this
back to ensure it comes back to cabinet
to consider the business case
thanks i think this is a little
premature
as i said we're waiting for
tenders to come in they should be in
this month
we have a growth meeting
early december at which time we will be
in a much better position to understand
what the costs and returns are likely to
be
if the situation is as you suggest then
bringing it back to cabinet may be an
option but uh let's not jump the gun
let's wait and see what the tender's
coming out thank you thank you mr busby
i'd like to move on now to item eight
over scrutiny committee update
i'd like to invite council mclaren to
provide an update
a verbal update
and
questions will be on clarification of
verbal update thank you thank you chair
yes
due to circumstances beyond my control
i'm afraid i've got to bring a verbal
report to members tonight
so i wish to report on the
joint overview and scrutiny committee
that was held on the 20th of september
2021
10 members representing both councils
were present at this meeting
the following are the agenda items that
were scrutinized and debated at the
meeting
there was the annual review of joint
homes and housing strategy and
homelessness and rough sleep in
reduction strategy 2019-2024
the housing needs and standards manager
gave a presentation to members of the
committee on the progress to date
the actions that are currently underway
and the future action planned over the
remaining two and a half years of the
strategy
questions by members covered a wide
range of subjects
ranging from rented garages rough
sleeper accommodation internet
availability translators repairs
and improved training for all
councillors in relation to gypsy and
traveller communities
members raised questions in relation to
the supply of affordable housing
and was the council adequately meeting
the needs of homeless people rough
sleepers and families requiring bed and
breakfast accommodation
and had the pandemic influence that
demand
queries by members whether the draft
local plan had currently identified the
numbers of affordable dwellings actually
needed especially during the past 18
months we were reassured that the
service had been flexible in responding
to demand during that time
so it was resolved by unanimous vote
that the content of the actions plan was
noted and asked for further information
on the day-to-day activities of the
action plan
it was resolved by seven votes to two
that the homes and housing strategy and
homeless and rough sleeping strategy
be reviewed twice yearly
there were two information bulletins
received by members
of the committee customer service update
and anti-social behaviour and these
bulletins can be found in the committee
agenda papers
there were questions to seek
clarification of some of the details in
the papers after which each of the
information bulletins were noted
members need to be advised that the
october joint overview and scrutiny
committee was cancelled as the proposed
work plan was to scope the relationship
between cabinets and the committee and
how that can be enhanced with regular
dialogue
unfortunately this was not possible due
to the possible changes taking place
within baylor district council cabinet
and the monitoring officer felt it would
be inappropriate at this time to
continue with this exercise
that concludes my report trey thank you
thank
um
you
there any questions for council mclaren
council beer
um thank you mr chairman um my question
to the chairman was this a joint
um overview and scrutiny committee
meeting it was a yes it was and who
chaired it uh councillor wallam from
mid-southwark
and the the third point to my question
then
um and are you saying that we're going
to dispense with this
from the next meeting that we're not
going to have a joint
anymore joint no i don't think i said
that actually
i didn't quite understand what you said
at the end of your comments regarding
that
at the end of this the final paragraph
though yeah yeah you referred to
the next meeting yeah thank you shall i
reread that for you council beer
okay
okay members need to be advised that the
october joint overview and scrutiny
committee was cancelled
as the proposed work plan was to scope
the relationship between cabinet and the
committee
and how that can be enhanced with
regular dialogue
unfortunately this was not possible due
to the changes taking place within the
baby district
council cabinet
and the monitoring officer felt it would
be inappropriate this time to continue
that exercise
apologies mr chairman to the chairman
i've forgotten we're in november
thank you makes sense
thank
are there you
other questions
then i'd like to move forward to the
next item which is uh recommendations
from cabinet and committees
and 9a bc 2121 gambling act 2005
statement of principles through yearly
adoption
i would like to invite councillor arthur
deputy leader
of the council to introduce
paper bc 2121
and to move the reclamation
recommendation in the report which is
3.1 that the draft revision gambling act
2005
statement of principles
document as attached as appendix a to
this report be adopted for publication
and to take effect for three years
unless sooner revised from january
31st january 2022
council rafi
thank you gentlemen yes in in the
absence of um councillors mayberry who's
the chairman of committee and carpendale
who's the vice chairman and um no leader
here to step into cover i'm afraid i'm
i'm the fourth choice
um
thank you
the purpose of this report is to ask
council to adopt the amended statement
of principles as recommended by baber
licensing and regulatory committee at
its meeting on the 15th of october 2021
it is a statutory requirement to review
and re-adopt the council's gambling
policy every three years
the decision to adopt the statement of
principles may only be taken by council
and cannot be delegated to the licensing
and regulatory committee
a consultation exercise was undertaken
for a 20 28 day period with one response
received and that response was from
gamble aware purely to advise of their
service
all changes to the policy are contained
within appendix b
the majority of amendments were purely
administrative with a few changes that
were as a result of the amendments to
the gambling commission's guidance
the recommendation has been read out by
the chairman
i would say that as you can probably
guess i'm not best placed to answer any
questions
but we do have emma rich bell with us
and also licensing officer catherine
greene
if you have any questions i'm sure she
will be able to answer them
chairman i propose the recommendation
and thank you
all right i'll now move to questions
council lindsay
thank you chair um
i'd like to
propose an amendment please to this
and that is that this council resolves
not to issue
a uh not to issue casino premises
licenses
that's under section 166
subsection one of the gambling act 2005
and this resolution applies from
today's date
thank you i can just come back
if i can just come in yes
can i just ask our chief exec to come in
here please
thank you chairman i just wanted to
clarify a point with the officer who's
with us catherine greene
my understanding but please do correct
me if i'm wrong that if we were to
introduce that change there would need
to be an additional consultation
exercise before the council could do
that i'm not saying the council can't do
that but it would need to go through a
consultation exercise to do that is that
correct or have i got the wrong end of
the stick which is perfectly possible
that is correct yes
so chairman just looking at councillor
lindsay um if you wanted to you could
bring that back as another item or you
could make an amendment that makes that
an additional consultation items
effectively adopt the statement again of
principles that you have in front of you
tonight but in addition then carry out
that further consultation because the
other aspect and again i'm going to look
at
the relevant officer is that you need to
adopt the statement of principles before
the close of this calendar year
and obviously if you delay the
implementation of this and carry out an
additional consultation you haven't got
a full council meeting to adopt those
principles in you'll run out of time so
if i can look at counseling lindsay if
it's something that uh that he and the
council are in support of as a principal
then i would suggest that's a second
motion that's dealt with alongside but
separate to the the gambling principles
then we could always bring back the
gambling principles early in the new
year
rather than delay the implementation of
what you have in front of you tonight
and hopefully that makes sense but if it
if it doesn't please do please do ask
um thank you thank you for that um
yeah i'm just looking at the act
and that particular
subsection that i was talking about it
does say
um
an order under one mind you it says an
order under subsection seven
may
may not
may require the licensing authority
to consult such persons or classes of
persons as they think are likely to be
affected by the resolution but the word
there is may
may require
um
i i don't know but i'm open to advice
but i just just wanted to interrogate
that a bit further because
that reads to me as though
it's not compulsory
thank you
advisor's team um they were give we were
given this option um that we had to
reconsult fully to prevent any judicial
review and opening the council up to
judicial review by not fully um
reconsulting
um yeah it's a question for catherine i
think we have not passed a no casino
resolution
um which we could have done it was it
2005 that came in so um
how many casinos have we got as a result
of not having a no casino resolution
and we are currently unable to um apply
for a casino there are none left under
the gambling act 2005 i'm afraid at
present so
council beer
thank you mr chairman as a member of
that committee
i did bring up about the casino license
and we were assured that there was none
in baber none in the pipeline and we
felt that it wasn't necessary to go down
that road at this present time so
i'm not saying that what council lindsay
is asking for isn't right or wrong but
that is really separate to all this we
need to accept this so that we can move
forward and then if if the
casino license and raise its ugly head
we can then sort that out in due course
thank you thank you
councillor dawson
um
clean
sub section seven where what you were
referring to sorry
so
have you got the um
you need to get the act in front of you
yeah yeah and then um
section 166 resolution not to it so you
can see no licenses sorry what page is
that on exactly
i don't know i'm looking at it on a web
form so it's just a section i looked up
section 166.
but
yeah i mean i wanted to make a point of
order as well
go on
the papers i apologize if the papers are
not available to us
how are members supposed to make a
judgment on this
and the second question for
clarification would this be along the
same lines of the motion that was
recently passed through mid-suffolk
district council
and although i can appreciate people
might want uniformity we are different
sovereign bodies but i don't think i can
happily vote and i don't think we can
happily discuss
an item for which we don't have full
information from officers presented
within the report
make a point of order on all this
sorry chair if that's all right
we're
could i just explain what the background
to this uh and it might help and then
there's no point having a debate on the
rights and wrongs of it
because either we can do it and or we
can't we need a consultation
um
and it sounds like we do
um
[Music]
but the the background is that that
mid-suffolk
are now
an authority that does not issue casino
licenses
and the reason for that is because they
had
there was much talk that there might
well be one in the pipeline and they had
one earlier that i think i don't know
all the background but some time ago
it was threatened
and
i mean whether or not
there's any
casinos now of course there are any
casinos in baby now that's not to say
someone will come along in the future
particularly if if mid suffolk are
ruling it out
you know the casino operator will then
go to well we'll try sudbury then or
hadley or the edge of ipswich
so
that's that's the reason i've raised it
come in here please thank you chairman i
i just thought i'd come in helpfully
much like councillor warden not being
present our monitoring officer can't be
present for sickness reasons but is
watching and able to advise us um so
alongside myself and john snell you have
also got the monetary officer in the
ether able to provide advice what she's
saying is that it is perfectly possible
to bring forward this issue it's a
discussion full council can have
technically though it is not an
amendment to this motion because it's an
additional thing it's completely it's
very similar but it's a completely
different thing not an amendment to the
motion you have in front of you so if
it's something that council would like
to proceed with much as council mclaur
mentioned then through our officers we
can bring a report back and you can
consider it as a stand-alone issue if
you wish to
although i would echo the point was made
mid-suffolk did go down that route
largely connected back to the snowasis
application as it was known several
years ago
there isn't going to be a casino on that
site mit suffolk narrowly decided to
retain its no casino motion that's
something they are now obliged to look
at on a regular basis as a result you
get into lots of double negatives i
would suggest that given that there is
zero opportunity for you to have a
casino at the moment not because of your
desires because there are no licenses
from government um that it's possibly an
unnecessary step but as i said if it's
something that this council wants to
consider we'll take that on advisement
take that away chairman and officers can
prepare the report and obviously give a
chance for the licensing committee to
consider that first so that the
licensing committee can put forward
recommendations to you but i'm conscious
you've got a mover and a seconder
so you do need to
having had a movement sector unless
council lindsey is happy to withdraw uh
his suggestion actually i'll take
actually i'm about to quit i'm going to
contradict myself you've got to move her
and set a second for an amendment that
you can't have so actually it can't be
an amendment so in that sense chairman
you're able to simply move on but if
council lindsay can indicate that if
you'd like us to bring that report back
as officers then we're more than happy
to do so as i say through the licensing
committee
yes thank you for that uh clarification
that
i'm sorry
thank you mr chairman
well these matters are particularly
complicated and
rules and regulations that come down
from central government are never made
to uh to be easy they're almost designed
to make lawyers profitable uh finding
their way around them um but can we when
this as this is gonna come back to us
can when it does come back can we know
one
where there are existing casinos within
striking distance if you like of us but
it's no good us putting up a chinese
wall around baber if there's one just
over the river in colchester
or somewhere like that and
two
is it likely that the government are
going to increase the number of licenses
for casinos to happen that's something
we need to know with the um
with the report when it comes back
i'll ask ourselves exactly that one yes
that's no problem at all and i think
some another counselor made the point
already you don't have the full detail
in front of you for this item tonight
which makes it difficult for you to
debate it absolutely we can make sure
counselor hinton that the report that
comes through covers both of those
aspects
i mean if i could just come back just
for a moment and say well following on
from that
the document we've got in front of us
does it differ significantly from those
of our adjacent councils
because if it does
um there's a problem if it doesn't then
there isn't a problem
catherine green may want to come in as a
licensing officer but i simply add no it
won't differ from many other councils
anywhere in the country because you are
so guided by the legislation around this
there isn't a lot of scope for deviation
anyway
um i would agree with that there isn't
really much scope for deviation the only
deviation would be if you were to adopt
the no casino resolution
council mccall
i'd just like to make a point of
clarification listening to both
catherine as the officer and arthur as
the chief executive
there isn't zero possibility of a casino
because no casino license has been
granted by government
nor is it likely to so this becomes
somewhat academic and i'd suggest we
move to the vote on the paper presented
before us
the other atom could be brought back to
council at a later point but i believe
that would be a separate motion and i'm
not sure whether it would require to be
a motion on
notice as opposed to emotion without
notice but i believe this is a motion
without notice
yes just to clarify that point
absolutely a bit of motion on notice and
of course it would come with an
accompanying report which would make it
a motion on notice uh just for
clarification in terms of moving to the
vote uh obviously you can move that as a
motion
without notice however i move that
however i'm conscious that you haven't
actually had any questions and debates
on the paper in front of you so you
might want to do that first unless there
aren't any and then by all means you can
move to the vote
council lindsay and then councillor
yeah thanks i just wanted to have a
chance to come back um on everything
that's been discussed and and say
um you know as far as i'm concerned
that's fine i understand
it's been ruled out constitutionally
because it's not a
an amendment technically and that's
that's the end of that um but just to
clarify
you you said something about um
it's got to be this has got to be
approved by a certain time and
but this can be approved anyway
and today
or otherwise and
i can bring forward an amendment at the
next meeting which is wednesday's
separation set promotion
yeah
so to help clarify yes so
apologies because i'm cutting across
catherine green but
yes you are obliged to review your
policy every three years
now is the time to do that because that
three year expires at the end of this
calendar year
but that doesn't preclude you looking at
the license or the gambling policy every
month if you really i'm not suggesting
you do
looking at it every month if you really
wish to
so approving this today doesn't preclude
you from looking at it again in january
for example and simply doesn't preclude
you from looking at the no casino aspect
that would have to come through as was
said as a motion unnoticed which
therefore would mean it would come with
a report but it would go through
licensing committee first so that full
council is advised by the licensing
committee rather than coming straight
here because you delegate that function
to the licensing committee who are adept
and used to looking at these issues in
detail on your collective behalf
this mr chairman i think well
i made it answered a question about it
uh as far as the debate on this uh item
is concerned i'm quite happy with it
having asked the question about whether
it differed from anybody else and i
don't think really there's any need for
us to to go into any more detail on this
as there is little scope for us to have
variance on it the one bit of scope this
council lindsay has brought up um we
can't do anything about tonight so we
might as well go to a vote
can i can i take just take that as a
seconder for my motion to move to the to
move to the matter in hand that's all
would that be a second though thank you
councillor hinton
well i was just going to sector but
that's fine i'm very pleased to stand
and uh also you've answered all my the
chief executives answered all my
questions and uh cancer lindsay um needs
to put it in the motion or bring it back
at a later date that's entirely up to
him but that can't be dictated by
tonight's meeting so i'm happy to go to
the vote
gambling act thank you
uh councillor
governance officer in rio
thank you chair um the vote is now in
progress on your app if you scroll down
to the blue line thank you
counselor be it may i take your vote
please
thank you
and counselor newman
thank you
thank you chair
that is uh 15 uh 17 votes for and two
abstentions
votes carried
thank you
assistant
can i
now move on to
item 10
a presentation regarding the code
response and recovery
once again
i'd like to invite council artie to
introduce this item
thank you chairman yes this time
i'm second choice
this is in council awards absence and
he's asked me to briefly introduce the
item
as you heard him say earlier in his
video
he is um
as council and chairman of cabinet keen
to increase debate and discussion for
all councillors at full council meetings
this is just one way to involve us all
in more of the strategic business of the
council and the issues facing our
residents and businesses
the purpose of this item is to consider
the current status of the district's
covid recovery
at the leader's request
officers have prepared a series of
slides to help set the background for
our current covid recovery position
and prompt discussion between us
after the presentation
after the presentation councillors will
of course be able to ask officers any
questions
of clarification but more importantly we
will have the opportunity to comment and
debate the topic
this will be shared with the senior
leadership team to help support and
inform them in any operational matters
and in partnership discussions with
other organizations
the comments and discussions will also
help inform cabinets thinking and
decisions as they may arise
to ensure our district our communities
and our residents are able to recover
and thrive
i'm also sure that our debate and
discussion here tonight will help inform
the development of the council's budget
for next year
which will of course come to overview
and scrutiny and then on to full council
in february 2022
i'll hand over to kathy nixon who
alongside fiona du hamel nadine matuja
and gavin fisk will give their
presentation
the presentation will be on the screens
in the chamber tonight but it has also
been circulated to you by email so you
can view it on your laptops if you
prefer and i ought to add just at the
end chairman thank you
any questions again not through me thank
you
good evening members
this evening myself and my colleagues
will focus on four key areas related to
covert recovery i'll provide a broad
overview then fiona will discuss the
local economic recovery
nadim matuja or who is our new interim
assistant director will focus on
communities and well-being and gavin
fisk will reflect on the recovery in
terms of housing and homelessness
and we suggest that we take questions
and at the end and before you move into
um debate
i want to begin by acknowledging the
broader suffer context for recovery
i think we would all agree
that we've seen the statutory and
voluntary sector partners across suffolk
working together at their very best
during the response to the pandemic
home but not alone the everyone in
project on homelessness to mention and
but two
as we move into recovery we now want to
build on that strong system-wide
collaborative working
and you will see on the slide
and before you the framework that
suffolk public sector leaders across
local government police health and the
local enterprise partnership will work
to as we plan with them the longer term
recovery strategy that will take us to a
better suffolk
essentially
they have agreed that their existing
broad strategic priorities for suffolk
set before the pandemic are still very
relevant to recovery
however they've picked out a few for
greater emphasis
these are health inequalities and
supporting individuals to improve their
physical and mental health and
well-being
wellbeing
locally led action to reimagine town
centers
housing and homelessness
enabling young people so impacted by
covert to fulfill their potential
and also environment and tackling
climate change
covert 19 has exacerbated some of the
inequalities we were already aware of
and also introduced new ones
and our commitment to reducing these
inequalities remains the same but we
need to adapt
and our pre-covert approaches in the
light of the changes we have experienced
and also to support our communities and
ourselves
to move to a new normality
before i come on to talk about our weber
recovery priorities i want to highlight
some of the covert impacts that we have
seen in weber
we have seen some of the highest rises
in universal credit claimants
we've also seen increases in
unemployment particularly for younger
people that's under 35
and for the over 50s
we have seen median earnings fall by 4.1
percent compared to 0.4 nationally
meaning that the median pay gap between
england and suffolk has got worse having
increased to 51 pines per week
we've also seen domestic abuse
rise by 9.6
we've seen antisocial behavior rise
by more than 18
we've also seen number of housing
register applicants in bands a and b
risen by more than 150 percent
we've we have seen mental health
referrals across all ages um in
increasing and refi and referrals into
the the range of agencies that deal with
that and are particularly high
i also just want to spend a moment on
what we have seen in terms of our
customer and resident contact
our calls have gone up by about a third
if we compare april to september 2021 to
the same period last year
and while phone contact remains highest
as the means of contact in the council
online contact is now fast catching up
nearly 70 000 transactions or inquiries
online have taken place since april of
this year
face-to-face contact has actually
reduced and on average we're now getting
about 87 um face-to-face contacts per
month
we absolutely expect that there will
always be people who need some
face-to-face contact
and we want to definitely provide that
for those most complex cases and
vulnerable groups
but our communities in their behavior
are clearly telling us that they want us
to do more online
and so now to some of our key covert
related risks and concerns
what what are they
the end of the uplift of universal
credit is clearly a concern
as is furlough ending
of course we'll all be very aware of the
current increase in suffer covert cases
and the challenge around the row light
of the booster and child vaccinations
of course and there's always that risk
of entering the national plan b
we hope it won't come but we need to
plan for it in case it does
we've also got inflation pressures we've
got normal winter pressures
we have possible housing evictions
and the number of job vacancies and
impact on specific sectors
in terms of operational recovery one of
our biggest challenges
is the is in building services where due
to lockdown restrictions non-emergency
repairs had to be put on hold and our
backlog has now risen to over 3000 cases
but we're also very aware
of the need to prepare well for what
could be a challenging winter to
minimize disruption both for us as an
organization and for our communities
so to that end we are currently
reviewing our risks and mitigation plans
related to what the cumulative impact
could be
of further potential covert disruption
of bad weather
and also other winter related pressures
such as non-covered related staff
sickness
greater pressure on disabled facilities
grants to keep people out of hospital
increased homelessness
inc
as well as
some of the issues we've seen around
things like
hgv
drivers
but amid all the challenges of recovery
there are of course opportunities
opportunities for more innovation and
technology through inc
through increased online activities but
also
and our technical businesses have seen
growth and we expect that to continue
also there are those um
opportunities of and
people's increased awareness of health
and also of the benefits of activities
but of course um also and there is that
increased awareness and determination
for partners to work even more closely
together than we have seen so far
and so um to round up taking all this
into account
um
we and
believe that our key strategic recovery
priorities in baby
to date
need to should actually reflect um our
our six key strategic priorities set
before the pandemic because they are
still very relevant indeed to the issues
that i've just highlighted
but in terms of our emphasis
we will focus on economic recovery
accelerating the customer and digital
program
playing our part to support good
physical and mental health
harnessing the community capacity and
volunteering that we saw during the
pandemic
supporting voluntary and community
sector agencies to recover and expand
housing and homelessness
and
ensuring that people have a stable and
affordable home
building on the reduced impact on the
environment that we saw during covert
and of course
the future office and agile working
but we need to keep all these priorities
under review
as we learn to live with and emerge from
covered and as we continue to understand
better the needs of our communities and
businesses
and so now i'm going to hand over to
fiona duhamel who will talk to us about
economic recovery thank you
could i ask the question mr chairman at
this point i mean the officer has just
painted a very black picture totally
different to what the national
government is telling us um and i've got
quite a few questions that i'd like to
put to her on those points
well
you know
the point is that this has come out
first and we've got to wait to put our
questions and and
really we're not responding to the
appropriate times i mean it's quite
depressing sitting here listen to this
thank you
sorry
german if i can just jump in at this
point so absolutely fine to ask
questions of course but the main point
of this is to provide an opportunity for
councillors to debate with one another
so counselor beer if you disagree with
with what any of the officers are saying
that's fantastic rather than challenging
the officer i think have that
conversation amongst yourselves that
that's the most important yeah but
that's a one we've got a one-sided view
here mr chairman we can't challenge that
at this moment and i'd like to on one
particular point um
you know housing repairs gone up to
3500.
that's that's disgraceful we should be
getting on top of that we should also be
getting encouraging people to get back
to the offices
and work and what have you uh
you know face to face the public out
there do want face-to-face uh meetings
and get them back to some sort of
normality i i understand that we have to
do things online i accept that but
you know you're making it sound as
though um
oh this is bad uh increasing anti-social
behavior well i've been telling you that
a lot
for years now you should be getting your
act together on that i'm sorry it's very
disappointing so chairman if i can i
think council of beer is absolutely
making the point i was trying to make
which is this is the opportunity for
councillors to challenge what they're
hearing but with each other
i'd also make the point that all of you
are part of the council so this isn't
officers telling you one thing
necessarily for you to disagree with in
terms of you should be getting your act
this is about what counsellors want us
to prioritize collectively so if i can i
would repeat the ask that that challenge
comes at the end
because i'm conscious otherwise there
are a series of presentations there's
three more to come to you may never get
to the end of the presentations if we
start to take questions and debate at
this point um and particularly i know it
has to be raised issue for example of
housing you're going to hear more about
that from from gavin fisk for example so
if i can
from the uh
mr chairman yes if i can make the
councillors patience uh we'll get
through the presentations as quickly as
we can and then there'll be plenty of
opportunity to debate the things in the
round
council mccrawl
i'm sorry to ask this but it was
mentioned that this had been circulated
i've looked through my emails i can't
find the email concerned
and i wondered if that perhaps might be
best sent round again
uh during the presentation
thank you yes we are actually working on
the problem as we speak um it is a very
large file and we have had some issues
trying to send it all afternoon so we
are might have to send it to you at two
emails but we are working on it as for
speak
in that case it may be that we need to
return to the
presentation at a later point thank you
yes if we could please uh have our
presentation completed i think that will
answer a lot of
uh our debate within for each other
thank you with each other
fiona
good evening councillors um i'm going to
be talking about the economic recovery
and um i want to start by saying
actually arthur if you could move us on
a slide
yeah i'm not actually going to start
with what's there i'm just going to give
you a few stats which uh
hopefully are um
well they're very positive i think in
terms of the amount of support our
businesses have had over the pandemic
period
so uh individual grant payments to
businesses have been around 2477.
and that's a total grants paid to our
businesses of over 42 million pounds to
support their resilience during the
pandemic
um they are a mix of discretionary and
um mandatory grants the discretionary
grants we called something called back
to business and we've paid 42 of those
grants
which totals around 688 000 pounds to
baby businesses um
and just the slide that you have up here
is really about the split of the type of
businesses that the back to business
grant has been paid out to um apologies
it's quite difficult to see on this
screen but the sort of brown area is
hospitality type businesses and and
that's the uh the largest area of
payment um the yellow area is events and
events hospitality so quite an
interesting uh split and hopefully when
you get slides you'll be able to look at
that in a bit more detail but it shows
that the sectors that we've been most
supporting through the grant payments
which is uh very much around our
visitor economy hospitality
and there's a section on retail as well
um if you could move some please so
i'm not going to dwell too much on this
slide this is really putting the context
of the work we've been doing in a more
national picture
so
talking about obviously some of the
government
recovery plans um which are emerging all
the time the regional plans around the
local enterprise partnership renewal
plans suffolk growth programme board
we're also working on a visitor economy
recovery plan um and coming right down
to the work that we've been doing here
in weber around our own recovery
proposals
and that includes refreshing our
economic evidence base and refreshing
our workspace evidence that we've
gathered
and looking at the work we're doing
around for example freeport which whilst
it isn't in this district well
undoubtedly in terms of number of jobs
created impact our district positively
thanks arthur so um
why do we need a recovery plan for the
economy well it's quite important really
because it helps us
as officers and as you as councillors to
help give direction to our businesses as
we start to move out of the pandemic
it also helps us to divert resources
where they're most most needed and it
also helps us to understand whether our
priorities are different now to where
they were before the pandemic and
kathy's already mentioned some things
that
have have changed or some things have
grown in
importance and it's helping to
understand some of that um in particular
uh digital infrastructure with people
working from home etc whether we see
that being a long-term thing or whether
we're seeing we see that being something
for the moment it is still needed
and it drives help that recovery plan
will help us to drive conversations with
our partners particularly around funding
so um before the pandemic just before
the pandemic we did a
a new economic evidence base it was
page document and it didn't it didn't go
any further than developing a new
framework which was around three key
themes innovation and creativity
being connected and sustainable and
skilled and successful and we've carried
those themes through into
the recovery proposals
so we have sort of a few moves on
we have uh drafted a recovery plan it's
been it's out with our stakeholders at
moment so um people like suffolk chamber
uh some of our
business organizations we're asking them
for comments and they're feeding
comments back which is great but it
effects effectively falls into three
strands um there's a react phase which
is kind of the phase we've been in
we're still in a little bit because
we're still spending some government
funding like the welcome back fund so it
is about still bolstering resilience but
it's very much now looking towards
recovery and in particular around
regrowth how can we help those
businesses get back to where they were
and start to grow
so i thought it'd be helpful if i just
gave you a few examples of some of the
good work that's been going on and the
work that's really helping our
businesses
um so sticking with those three themes
around connected and sustainable
we obviously appointed some time ago now
a sustainable travel officer who's been
working with a number of our councillors
and inviting lots of comments from our
communities on sustainable travel in
particular walking and cycling
we held i think as mentioned at the
beginning we held a local energy
showcase uh
last week or week four i've lost track
um we had over 220 businesses and
individuals that attended that um and it
was a really really successful event we
it didn't cost the council anything we
managed to get sponsors to sponsor the
whole event
but it really helped
our communities and our businesses
understand more about local energy
and why is that important to the economy
because it's a very fast growing sector
it's where the future jobs and the
future skills of future jobs will come
from and where future skills are going
to be needed it's a really really key
and very fast growing sector
we've been working on active travel
schemes which has included things like
new cycle parking in in sudbury and in
hadley
and we're working very much with
partners around
roll out plans for high speed broadband
and i'm talking about one gigabit upload
download speeds for anybody that's
particularly techie here
um
and something that's becoming is going
to be very obvious soon is about new new
solar carports in our town center so the
the one in sudbury that we're talking
about which is being funded through some
external funding that we've secured and
hopefully will come forward as a great
project for our town centre
good
next one
thank you
we in 2020 november 2020 in the heart of
the pandemic we launched an innovation
awards for our businesses
again we had over 100 businesses
involved 11 categories
and some fabulous
support from our sponsors for our small
businesses came out of those awards
which is still going on today and uh
the businesses at one and ferguson's
delhi in hadley was delighted to be a
winner and i know they've been really
pleased and following that through ever
since um and
that those innovation awards have led us
to set up an innovation board which has
some uh key stakeholders from across the
region actually helping to support some
of the work we're doing across baber
and that includes people like tech east
uh who are big players in the east of
england um we have also created an
innovation network which includes a
monthly monthly newsletter to our
businesses and just to be clear
innovation is not just about tech
businesses any business can innovate and
one of the things about the innovation
awards that was so great is that we
celebrated
small businesses who had tweaked their
general business practices to either
help with covid or to help post coverage
so it isn't just about technology
businesses it's it's widespread and
that's what we want to promote
um we've secured funding for digital
skills support for some of our very
small businesses particularly linked to
another initiative which has been hugely
successful which is the virtual high
street
giving our high street businesses an
online presence and again we've secured
funding we started it in sudbury and
we've secured funding to roll it out to
hadley
we've had some i think we've got about
200 businesses currently on the virtual
high street just for those two towns
we're looking now at how we can roll it
out to the wider district particularly
through some of our some bigger and
smaller villages because the good thing
about the virtual high street is it is
not limited just to town centres it's
really able anywhere that has a a
property a retail property is uh able to
to be part of the virtual high street
and we've created something called
pop-up
innovation hubs uh through something
called innovate local that we came up
with
and that's led to a market stall in
hadley
being provided for free for a small
business who wants to go and trial their
business idea it's been hugely
successful i think we're now fully
booked up until the end until the end of
christmas um so we'll be looking at what
the follow-on is from that and we're
getting some great feedback and case
studies from some of those businesses
and as i said earlier we've refreshed
our workspace study to have a look at
what the impact actually is at the
moment on some of our demand studies
that we had around what businesses need
in terms of premises
and the final area is around being
skilled and successful
we've submitted bids so we've submitted
a bid to the community renewal fund
around economies and healthier lives
programme very much in partnership with
our communities team looking at how we
can really support
people of any age actually to
be healthier in their communities and of
course how you work and where you work
is part of that
we've worked strongly with suffolk
county council around the kickstart
program um i won't go into the detail of
that if anyone wants more details i can
give it afterwards
and the kickstart programs have been
very very successful in providing
employment for 16 to 24 year olds um
we're looking at new workspace based on
that workspace study so in hadley we are
bringing forward proposals for 10 new
workspace units again that's what the
demand study is telling us
and we've been working with the
university of essex around developing
something called a knowledge transfer
light partnership
which is based on providing
benefits to very small businesses that
they couldn't normally afford um and the
curiosity festival so my voice is going
we're planning for easter 2022.
sorry
and we've been doing quite a lot of work
on inclusive placemaking and
partnerships the work in our town
centres
we've set up uh groups we've also got in
sudbury a cultural subgroup now which is
god my voice is going sorry
i'm talking too quickly um which is all
about really bringing together partners
to try to work together on joint
projects and initiatives
uh i've talked about the virtual high
street sorry author if you go if we go i
won't really uh talk too much more about
that other than it has been a great um
and very well supported initiative by
our businesses
and the final case study really is
around the local energy showcase event
which i mentioned earlier which is um
the first that we've done um we had
we've had recognition really across the
east for it at the moment
and we're just taking feedback to see
how we can make it better if we're
looking to run it again next year
a very quick slide just about jobs
because actually all of this comes back
to job numbers really
in the end
some of these schemes that are on the
slide here
are not necessarily
in place yet
but they will deliver significant
numbers of jobs and then you've got
other schemes that are already well
underway like sprawton which of course
is already delivering large amounts of
jobs
but we've got some future sites coming
forward like brantham um
chilton woods in sudbury and uh worsted
there's a food enterprise zone there
that we're really trying to now work
with partners to bring forward those
jobs
i'm glad this is the last slide i'm not
sure what voice is gonna hold out
um and looking to the longer term we're
looking very much at creating a new
economic strategy we've redone the
evidence base that we did 12 months ago
because it feels out of date now
so we're very much looking at how we can
write a new strategy
which can build upon the recovery work
that was already doing but start to look
to the future a little bit more in terms
of where the new jobs and how we can
help to support new jobs
we're looking to develop an inward
investment strategy inward investment
isn't just about bringing new new
businesses to the district it's about
helping existing business i think 75
percent of input investment activity is
around supporting existing businesses to
grow but we're very keen that we develop
a bespoke strategy around how we can
best do that
and we will continue to build those
strong partnerships with local regional
and national partners especially around
funding
um we are looking potentially doing
another set of innovation awards in 2022
and i think the support and feedback
we've had already around the local
energy showcase event is is potentially
around doing another one of those in
2022
and we will continue to support
businesses across the district
to ever changing circumstances really um
but it's not all a negative picture
we've really had some uh significant
activity going on alongside alongside a
major grants programme and hopefully uh
it's given you a good taste of that
tonight thank you i think i'm heading
over to nadine to talk about communities
good evening everyone um my name is
nadine matuja i've
met some of you haven't met some of you
so
hopefully i'll be able to
have some of those meetings i'm just
going to talk to you about
communities i am both my colleagues have
spoken about a system-wide response and
it's also important that within the
organization
you get a flavor of what we've been
doing actually across service areas in
terms of responding to corvid
um
i'm going to pick up on about four or
five areas i want to talk about ledger
services i'm going to talk about a broad
range of interventions that we've been
applying in terms of supporting
communities to recover and i'm also
going to talk about how we're moving
forward on a system-wide level in
relation to responding to some of the
challenges that kathy was actually
referring to particularly in terms of
the impact of covert so
beginning with leisure services
um ledger services right across the
country um there's been is quite a
significant impact as a result of
corvette
kovit
you know we have seen
some leisure services um and
particularly the districts talk about
the potential impact in relation to
being a sustainment sustainable in the
longer term
we've also identified that
ledger services alongside the lg have
actually lobbied government in relation
to
support in terms of recovery and some of
you will remember in december 2020
government actually listened to that
call and identified as rescue package
for particularly for leisure services
it's important that when we think about
leisure services we think about those
services in a number of contexts one of
those contexts is how ledger services
can actually provide a real value in
terms of supporting people to recover
both from a physical and a mental health
and well-being perspective
but equally leisure services the work
that we've done in relation to
decarbonisation
really help us in terms of
delivering some of our sustainability
aspirations
it's also important to recognize that
the work that we invest now in terms of
leisure and in particular in terms of
engaging
commun communities and those individuals
who are actually most at risk
that only not only not only does it
actually benefit those individuals and
families in terms of their own physical
and mental health but it also in the
longer term reduces pressure in relation
to the nhs and adult social care as well
so where are we in terms of leisure
services locally well so you can see
from this slide
um in spite of the national picture in
terms of leisure
um we've actually started we've
recovered actually quite well in terms
of so what you have there is um health
and fitness membership on your first
slide you'll identify we're now actually
at um close to pre-pandemic levels
and then in terms of swim academy
exactly the same picture what that goes
to show is that what we've shown locally
is some real leadership and what's also
enabled us to actually understand is how
the local authority has actually worked
with this partners particularly in this
case abbycroft to actually make sure
that we're able to actually recover that
pace so whilst other places across the
country
have been actually struggling here in
berber we've actually been
really booking the trend and actually
making sure that we're able to provide
the support that our residents need
i'm just going to move on to
um the most recent survey from sports
england i think there's a
and i just wanted to touch on that quote
um because i think and i'd just like to
part that because i'll come back to that
a little bit later on so
what that quote really actually
references that
the impact of kovic so for example if
you would anyone at the moment review
has a disproportionate impact
particularly in terms of deprived more
disadvantaged communities and what the
real emphasis and the importance of that
is
those same people will actually be
actually the most at risk and they're
the ones that we need to support but
just in terms of um activity so this was
a survey where we only got the results
last week and what it identifies in
terms of inactivity there's been a 4.8
increase in terms of people who are
actually fairly active it's around 1.9
and those people are actually active
we've actually seen a decrease
i'm going to
move us on
to our next slide
and so
we're focusing on investment in leisure
services
so hadley pool we've refurbished and
we've modernized we've supported that by
approximately 2.5 million pounds of
investment by the um
by the council supplemented by a further
200k
but from the town castle and 150 000
pounds from sports england we've seen a
two point four million pound extension
referral king fisher leisure center and
as part of our aspiration in terms of
decarbonisation and it's what fiona was
really saying in terms of the 40 beer
solar carpool
which assumed directly on the sudbury
side which will then combine with the
battery storage will feed into the
ledger center so it's going to lead to
actually reducing energy costs so it's a
real example how community services and
the work that fiona's been doing on a
system-wide level actually benefiting
not just in terms of sustainability but
also in relation to
leisure services and modernisation going
forward
some of you will remember that you
received a presentation on the 2nd of
september
and what that identified was a real
comprehensive range of interventions
and
um what i'm going to do is not go
through all of those interventions but
what i am going to do is actually just
showcase and actually highlight some of
the work that's been going on and it'll
really give you an insight and flavor of
some of the recovery work that's been
taking place so the active schools
program which aims to reduce obesity and
inactivity in children and it's been
delivered in eight locations across
um baby those were acton saint gregory
saint
peter's sudbury um great welding field
woodall hadley beaumont buress walt hall
and popkin
the active well-being project that
supports older adults to stay active
it's currently running in glamsford and
shortly with plans to explain that
further and pre-school holidays for
children and young people continue at
our leisure centers
we're also looking at putting together a
paper because we recognize
particularly in relation to people who
want to achieve young people those
people who can't swim in relation to
what that will look like right across
the landscape
just bear with me a second
in terms of the community grants program
in 2021 we've provided community grants
for about 107 projects with a total
value of around 600 000 pounds
this included financial at the support
for 48 community organizations that were
directly providing community corporate
response in their local communities
in addition we administer 63 member
locality grant awards totally 47k and at
the end of september 2021
um halfway through this financial year
308 thousand pounds in community grants
have been allocated to 45 projects
we've been working with partners to
support committee groups with advice and
restart grants to enable them to get
back up and running almost back towards
pre-pandemic levels
and you will not believe this that my
laptop has just
apologies
bear with me
just while nadine's doing that just if
councils haven't spotted it the slides
have now gone out by email so you should
have them in your inbox uh for you to
view them so yourselves
i think thanks to robert who's managed
to compress them sufficiently to get
them into an email
no no it's fine
okay whilst that once that comes on and
um i wrote these notes i i should be
able to uh
take you through them
from memory
sorry chair can i just make the point
that it seems to me that there's a lot
of information that we're getting here
that we will also get in the next two
reports
i don't want to hear it twice
yeah
yeah that's you gary
nice pants
okay sorry i'm i'm
back on apologies everybody
um
so in terms in terms since may 2021 nine
sports clubs have been awarded combined
total of 15k and the favorite allocation
of community restart funding and 18
community groups have been awarded a
combined total of 21k the grants
application process has also been
digitized
in terms of community safety and just
cons and conscious of what my colleague
kathy had said but also council to b in
terms of
anti-social behavior so we've reviewed
the anti-social behavior process
including the information sharing
protocol we've introduced a new case
management system and we've also
looked at developing a new set of tools
in terms of community triggers
cctv has been enhanced right across the
district with the view that we will have
27 cctv cameras
installed we're aiming to install a cctv
camera in bellevue we were hoping to do
that this week
we've not been able to do that but
subject to weather we hopefully will do
that next week
and we're going to deliver that through
a contract with west suffolk council
we've also agreed to lease a mobile cctv
camera fully dedicated to berber from
west suburb council
reported incidents of domestic abuse
have increased during the pandemic
that's a national picture it's not just
unique to
baby we've been involved in domestic
abuse awareness campaigns we've also
secured funding for a dedicated domestic
abuse officer in our
housing solutions team
in addition to that staff are being
trained as domestic abuse champions in
order to recognize the signs of domestic
violence and being able to signpost for
specialist support
in terms of social prescribing
building on the success of the social
prescribing work that we've already
taken in partnership with primary care
what we are aiming to do now is extend
that further to youth prescribing
and
and we're working with partnership
partner agencies to agree a joint
funding strategy outcomes and priorities
we have a view in relation to youth
prescribing that what we want to do is
actually have one officer in each of the
five ints
and potentially base the the specialist
in schools
we have two proactive int's in baby in
sudbury and south rural
informed by and both of those ints
are their work is informed by a local
public health needs assessment this
enables them to actually work with local
communities in terms of addressing the
broader and wider discernments of
community health
in terms of well-being strategy
and you'll note that you actually
adopted a well-being strategy
earlier in september
and that's to complement the sports and
physical strategies well what
the plan next is to make sure that we
actually have synergy between both of
those strategies and we will start
working towards developing a delivery
plan
i should say that this list is not
exhaustive but that broadly gives you a
flavor of some of the work that's
currently been underway some of the
highlights that i just wanted to just
touch on which i'm sure you
will be aware of we've delivered the
women's tour we've been developing
particularly interventions and
delivering interventions in terms of
chill chat and play i've already spoken
about integrated neighborhood teams
which i'll touch on in a short while and
we've also extended the school holiday
program
across 11 projects which run right
across the district
when kathy was
describing some of the challenges that
we could potentially face
she identified and
some of those issues whether whether
they were related to inflation whether
we need to under social behavior or or
the exacerbation of inequalities and
it's quite important that what we do as
a council we actually prepare for all
scenarios so what the better case
the worst case but also recognizing in
some cases it's too early to say
and to
understand what we mean by preparing for
those scenarios
author and
um you
you've taken two slides okay one of the
things an area of work that we're
focusing on
is
what we call population health
management now what we're going to try
to identify within population health
management is try to understand better
some of the issues and the challenges
that are facing our population so it
will enable us to actually pre-determine
some of the risks and challenges facing
our communities and in that context and
in that regard what we'll be able to do
identify particular insight in relation
to
where we need to actually focus our
resources and our energies
that means thinking about the work that
we've already done in relation to corbyn
using insight lead
working with our communities so really
harnessing that support
and work and when we're able to
understand evidence and intelligence
better what we're also able to do is
really segment and stratify exactly
where we need to actually focus our
resources so that's about ensuring that
we can focus on the place and actually
people that will enable us to give us
the best chance in relation to making
sure that those people who are
potentially disproportionately impacted
we're able to actually target resources
to meet those people's needs
and it's that targeted approach that we
really need to actually focus on in
relation to supporting people to recover
the best of what we can
out of colbit
i'm now going to
touch on
these final two slides which is which
colleagues have already spoken about
which is
around digital inclusion
so
some of the challenges some of the
opportunities that we've identified
particularly in relation to
digital inclusion so we have
88 of residents which actually have
access to um digital um
internet
and what we've also identified we've
going to see a real shift in digital
participation between 2013 and 19 in
terms of usage in 2019 only 8.3 of the
population of 16 plus were not were not
able to use the internet we also
recognize in terms of digital inclusion
we need to actually understand better
in relation to who is who is it in terms
of those communities most at risk that
we need to provide supports in that
context marginalized groups or those
communities which are actually on the
periphery and identifying what is it
that we need to do in terms of what
prevents digital access but also in
relation to what are the measures that
we need to put in place
um it's also important to
no note from a risk management
perspective in terms of digital
inclusion
behavior actually reports far more
positively compared to the wider county
a lloyd survey indicates
it's about much more than access it's
also about developing digital skills
which were some of the points that fiona
was actually referring to in her
presentation
in a recent survey that we did with
tenants we identified that 54 of tenants
were fairly or very confident in
relation to internet users what we now
need to do is understand the thematic
issues that that service identified and
start thinking about the work that we
need to do in terms of making sure that
those tenants get the appropriate level
of support both in terms of
gaining online skills but also in
relation to any other issues that that
survey has identified
and finally in relation to
my final slide
our cover recovery in the digital space
ranges from capacity building for those
people who need it
it means that we've got to work on
building a digital champion network
which will enable
um people to actually get some of that
peer-to-peer support from one another
and a system that enables access to
digital service lending re-homing and
obviously from that there's clear
sustainability benefits
we have tapped into a digital inclusion
network to understand better
and ensure we are able to develop best
practice locally
through
council council mccraw was referring to
the work that we're doing in terms of
libraries so it's through our live
provision we're making ipads available
to people not only able to access
hardware they can also act become more
proficient in developing their own
online skills which would then actually
benefit engagement with councils
including accessing services and build
confidence
our website pages will be launched soon
this will help further develop the
online offer and improve skills and
confidence too
our digital approach is to ensure that
our residents are able to benefit from
the wide range of priorities and
outcomes that we want to achieve for the
residents of baby whether they're in
economic education or accessing services
we want to make the customer journey
when engaging with the council and the
quality and responsiveness of our
services as seamless as possible
i'm now going to hand you over to gavin
who's going to talk to you about housing
thank you
um good evening members just before i
talk about some of the housing
challenges
on that slide i just want to come back
to some of the points raised earlier in
the presentation
in relation to the outstanding work
or
work in progress as it's known um it's
clear that there is a national challenge
as a result of the lockdowns last year
we as a
council would conduct typically about 12
000 repairs per year
with the national lockdowns clearly we
couldn't undertake that work and clearly
that has has built up um and has then
been reported this year when when
residents have been able to do so
um the average work in progress is
around about 1500 to 2000 jobs at any
one time we're currently approximately
3500
just in response in terms of some of the
things that we're doing we're utilizing
external contractors wherever possible
we're obviously clearly prioritizing the
work based on its importance and
priority
we're giving opportunities for staff to
work additional hours and support the
efforts
we've recently introduced new sketch and
software to to allow us to be more
efficient
in in our ability to get around the the
geographic area um we're actively
managing material shortages with our our
supplier travis perkins
and we're also maximizing the retention
and recruitment of the trades team to to
optimize it
and i think um it's important to also
just reflect um on the past 18 months
because our repair service did not stop
throughout the pandemic
they did not work from home they were
out there every day whilst they wouldn't
have been carrying out routine repairs
they were carrying out urgent and
emergency repairs
they were turning around void properties
in order for us to let those to those in
greatest need
they were cleaning all of our housing
sites to prevent covid in in sheltered
accommodation um and reduce the risk um
and of course there was the lees project
in sudbury which has received uh
recognition nationwide in terms of the
the speed at which that project was
turned around um as well as offering
mutual aid to uh to to equivalent
organizations that were in need of
support so i think i'd like to take the
opportunity to celebrate the work of the
the building services team during that
time
um if i come on to the the slide in in
front of you um some of the housing
challenges clearly we've seen an
increase um in demand whether that be
for those in priority needs uh those in
temporary accommodation and those rough
sleeping and that's been a trend that
we've seen throughout the pandemic uh
right up uh until till till now
and as we know there will be a range of
factors contributing to this and it's
important that we can demonstrate to you
and to our residents that through our
covert recovery our response to those in
greatest need that will be to mitigate
the impact uh and the effects
um so if you just take me onto the next
slide after
in terms of um
housing recovery um there has been
significant uh funding made available to
local authorities throughout the
pandemic to to manage the effects of um
everyone in and i think we should
celebrate the work that was done across
the county um last year in response to
everyone in 63 rough sleepers off the
streets of suffolk over 24 hours
to prevent
those from from becoming uh ill or
unwell
and at its height during the last year
we had more than 350
uh individuals or families in temporary
accommodation um across suffolk
in response i think uh the response in
suffolk has has been really well
received in terms of additional funding
uh now to support the recovery efforts
and you may already be aware that
suffolk public sector leaders
recently ring fenced a million pounds to
aid
to aid uh housing uh homelessness in
inequalities um baby have just been
allocated uh quarter of a million pounds
through the household support fund um
and that will support those with uh
additional housing costs um and prevent
homelessness between now and march next
year
baber have been awarded
just this week 46 000 pounds from the
government support for vulnerable
renters this winter
we're still intending to deliver free
units of accommodation to support our
rough sleeping work
and we've already begun the work to
co-produce our next bids to to the
government in relation to rough sleeping
so they're all positive um but if we
move on to some of the additional work
that's been done by weber and
mid-suffolk and suffolk authorities
i think what the pandemic did in
relation to to housing inequalities and
homelessness was was really galvanize uh
the work of authorities um and if i
could just pick out on on that slide um
some of this didn't come down to to
money some of it came down to working
differently um in the way that we we
manage our business so the introduction
of a rough sleeper coordination database
prior to the covet pandemic
we obviously only had a limited
knowledge of who was out there and who
may be sleeping rough
and through the coordination database
we've now got all of the partner
agencies working together
to give us a really rounded richer
picture of the individual
their needs the gaps in support where
they may be receiving support
and that work has really been developed
and i think it's probably an exemplar
although it hasn't been been highlighted
beyond uh suffolk authorities um but
what is now allowing us to do is
identify trends identify demand
and and support those individuals not
just now but but in the longer term as
well
if i move on to the the next slide um
we've we've got a number of priorities
as as baby mid suffolk and as suffolk
authorities and the first of those is no
return to rough sleeping
as well as preventing homelessness
we know that a recent report by lord
curselake found that homeless prevention
is is a name which
crisscrosses government
departments bring with it social and
financial returns
research has shown that public spending
would fall by 370 million if 40 000
people were prevented from experiencing
one year of homelessness nationally
and the human and social costs of rough
sleeping are extensive and much of it is
born out in the health and criminal
justice system
and within our communities and we know
that analysis of public spending shows
that if we can
on average quickly resolve an episode of
rough sleeping at a cost of
approximately hundred pounds
um it would rise to twenty thousand
pounds if that individual was uh
persistently rough sleeping for twelve
months
if i take you on to next priority uh
more homes and developing healthier
lives the reality is to resolve many of
the challenges we must prioritize
prevention and create more housing
capacity for people to sustain a life
away from the streets what is required
is a range of housing and accommodation
options along with wraparound support
and to pick out one of those examples in
terms of what we're doing and what we
need to do
is the evidence around some of the
initiative models to
effectively
prevent
reduce
and resolve for our sleeping and that's
housing first
but in addition the investment in
employment support to give people skills
and opportunities back into work
along with the products that you can see
in front of you
on the next slide
the third element that we are focused on
is no evictions into homelessness
and the reality is that rather than
tackle the symptom we need to tackle the
cause and by doing so avoid the the
extensive cost to the wider system
we know that london school of economics
has estimated that the current predicted
uk unemployment rate um
420 thousand tenant households might be
in arrears by the end of 2021 and we
know that analysis by joseph rantri
foundation has shown that as a result of
the cuts to universal credit in
september that could result in uh
nationally half million people being
swept into poverty
we're already actively monitoring the
effects of the recent eviction ban
ending and suffolk authorities are
identifying trends and pinch points in a
number of eviction notices being awarded
and sharing best practice
the demand and supply of housing is of
course not a local authority problem to
resolve there is a clear appetite from
housing associations locally to help us
and prevent homelessness and find secure
homes
for people who are homeless and the
national alliance homes for cafe exist
to encourage such housing associations
to do more on this by asking its members
to sign up to nine homelessness
commitments
and i'm pleased to say that in suffolk
what we've seen is a real trend
of local authorities working with
registered providers over the past 18
months
with really a galvanizing of agreeing
guiding principles that local
authorities and registered providers
will follow
to prevent evictions
and that the reliance on on perhaps
local authorities historically uh being
responsible for reducing renter ease or
preventing evictions
and then if we move on to um
uh to a better deal for everyone and and
and to sum up
um central government directives last
year and and the funding to match really
helped galvanize local agencies that
that i and colleagues work with
with a real common objective to saving
lives um and this was led by great
strategic buy-in um liberating many from
process and procedure um and and perhaps
often the deemed silo structures that
perhaps we've worked in in the past
what we've seen over the past 18 months
is how stakeholders have formed joint
working groups shared best practice and
provided oversight in terms of the
response meeting more regularly and
discussing some of the challenges and
this increased sense of shared
responsibility and impetus um can only
really see us act as agencies um in a
more collective and collaborative way
taking responsibility for the clients
and
the the situations that i've presented
to you this evening thank you
so chairman if i can that's the end of
the presentation conscious we've given
you a huge amount of presentation there
and thank you for your patience in terms
of uh allowing us to take you through
that unsurprisingly you can imagine
having been addressing kofi for a two
year period that's why there's quite so
much that's been done but there's also
still a lot to do
but as councillor arthur said right at
the start this really is an opportunity
for you to now have those discussions
yourselves to help inform the future
direction of the councils around this
topic but also help inform the thinking
around the budget for february as well
so i'll hand back the chairman in terms
of debate and comment
point of order i do have a point of
order chair and i i beg members um
understanding of why i'm making this
point there are 37 slides there um a lot
of content if we are to debate and
discuss those all the content of all 37
of those slides
i don't see that we'll get make any real
progress i think there is obviously
discussion to be had about all those
things but i take the view
that this is information being supplied
to us
as to being
what the effects are now we could argue
about whether it's true or not in any
number of ways but effectively that's
what we're being told this these are the
facts
how they are dealt with well we can see
how some of those are being dealt with
so from that point of view i'd like to
suggest that carrying out a debate
on the topics described in these
voluminous slides
with more detail behind them is probably
pointless
perhaps it can be dealt with at another
time and that's all i'm going to say i
hope that the chair and the members will
take account of that
thank you um council macro
i i do have a second for that motion if
it was necessary chair just to be clear
cousin i'm not sure i heard a motion i i
think i know what you were saying
of it
is the uh
okay
if that is the feeling of of members
please can i have a show of hands please
mr chairman there will be an opportunity
for us to to make comments on all this
at a later date oh absolutely
i agree
the whole the whole point as i said is
that
our officers
have produced something which some of
our counselors might not be aware of and
therefore uh you know where we stand
yeah you are aware
but can i just i'll just thank our
officers for for what they've done it's
excellent
[Applause]
thank you
look it's all one and goodness just
saying yeah that's all fantastic
information and we'll take it on board
but i would have thought that the
purpose of doing this was to ask us for
some advice as to where they want to
take it where we want to go
personally i felt that
i was expecting something different i
was expecting it
to be covid related rather than just
general i think it was 80 of that we
would expect to happen anyway
the 20 that was
driven by kovid was lost i'm afraid
um and it will be difficult for us to
just debate on as you said 37 slides but
if there's anything that you feel that
we should
take forward
and you need a steer on then i think
that needs to come back to us as soon as
possible
if i can chairman conscious i think
there was a couple of hands i think
cancer airs wants to come in as well but
i think what i'm hearing from customer
cause motion and what council busby just
said is that the item effectively is
deferred if you want to come back for
further consideration that's fine and it
outside of the meeting if there are
specific points that counselors either
wish to question further or would like
to clarify ahead of any debate or full
council then of course we we can do that
yes thank you excellent presentation
thank you so much and gavin i won't name
names but i would like to compliment a
certain gentleman who often walks the
meadows and looks for the people who
who i haven't got anywhere to sleep and
the staff that work behind the scenes
so pass on my thanks and congratulations
because i think they should be mentioned
thank you
claire kessler
just to add that can i suggest that the
method of discussion amongst members be
presented between members of the council
by email perhaps the group leaders can
get together and decide on what the most
appropriate means of going through these
37 slides should be it may not need to
be in the full debate in the chamber it
may be through a briefing method but i
think we do need to do it
thank you councilman mccall can i have a
show of hands in so we can move on to
the next item
that's unanimous thank you members
can i again say thank you to the the
officers who
brought that through
just for the benefit the officers
sometimes less is more
so if i may for castle busby and other
councillors sometimes trying to
summarize two years where the covid is
quite difficult and getting it down to
37 slides i think is particularly
impressive but i'm conscious that can be
a slog to go through in the guts chamber
taking care of husband
right i'd like to move on to item 11
please uh to receive port reports from
cabinet members
as the leader mentioned in his
announcements he has
reintroduced a rolling schedule for cab
of cabinet members providing reports
at each full council meeting
councillor davis and councillor holt
will be doing the first of these this
evening
however councillor holt
has sent in his apologies so therefore
the report is for noting only
any question from members can be sent to
the cabinet member by email
the purpose of this is to provide even
greater transparency and access to
for all councillors to all cabinet
members
and to influence the direction of the
respective portfolios
once councillor
davis has presented his report then
there will be an opportunity for
councillors to ask him any questions
although
you cannot of course speak
uh of course ask questions of an
operational nature i suspect the cabinet
members will have to refer these
questions to officers
and
and so much
so such questions may be better held and
raised outside of their meeting
you may instead want to focus your
questions more politically so that you
are more directly questioning each
cabinet member
about the nature of the political
direction they are bringing to their
portfolio
councillor davies cabinet member for
communities would you like to present
your report
um yes thank you very much but given
the comprehensive report from nadim
i don't think i should add an awful lot
it was such a good presentation that um
i'll just
basically wrap up i'll do i'll take
councillor busby's advice and it'll be
less rather than more
i think fundamentally as we all do all
our portfolios but especially within the
communities team we have an end goal
and for me that end goal is the mental
wealth of our residents and that
includes everybody in this chamber
whether they recognize it straight away
or not
everything we in the communities do
as part of our various health and
wellbeing work including everything in
the paper
increases the mental wealth of our
residents from free swims for our
under-16s during the school holidays and
the myriad of holiday activities across
the district for example one i went to
at grant cornard last week
during the half term and got roped into
pumpkin carving and
taken out the guts and everything to
ensure and that we can help those with
various limitations to be able to live
independently
and that also includes everyone in
between by increasing physical activity
and mental well-being
we are increasing mental wealth
and that is worth investing in
when you enrich your men enrich your
mental wealth it makes us all more
resilient
and increasing increases overall
well-being it also means you are more
equipped to support yourself your
friends and your family
you will see by the paper the vast range
of work undertaken by our superb
communities team both over the past 19
months when the pandemic first hit to
the present day as we work towards
recovery
and we have clearly set out the ongoing
work we are committed to achieving
and i'll leave it there i was going to
go through all the various bits but i
don't need to do that
no thank you councillor davis thank you
very much and i thoroughly agree with
you about the mental health side and
hopefully my my charity will support
that even further thank you
are there any questions for
clarification of counselor davis
update even for clarification
okay i shall they'll move on to item 12
then
which is the bc 21 20 21 22
political balance and composition of
committees
i would like to
invite the deputy monitoring officer to
introduce the report
thank you
john
thank you chair
i'm pleased to introduce this paper bc
2122 which seeks the council's approval
of a revised calculation of the
political balance and numerical
allocation of seats to committees
this revision is necessary following
councillor
mavisi's move from the conservative
group to the independent group
you will note from appendix a that this
has resulted in just one seat changing
a seat on the planning committee has
transferred from the conservative group
to the independent group
chairman i'm sure that many councils
will be aware that there is a meeting of
the planning committee tomorrow
wednesday the 3rd of november
as it would be entirely unreasonable for
any new committee member to read the
agenda papers between now and tomorrow's
meeting
i would like to make an alteration to
recommendation 2.1 to insert the words
with effect from the 4th of november
2021
at the end of this recommendation
this will enable the existing committee
members as summoned by the agenda to
participate in the meeting tomorrow
if not we're in no better position
chairman i'm happy to ask answer any
questions that you may have and would
ask for proposer and second yeah
thank you
thank you
the recommendation
recommendation that the committee size
and numerical
allocation of seats be approved as
detailed in
appendix a to this report with the
effect from the 4th of november
2021
council mclaren
on page 105 it says this conservative
has got 14 seats it hasn't it's got 30.
just to clarify for members because
others watching on youtube if they are i
won't have heard that answer but yes
it's the number of committee seats
rather than a number of counselors sorry
but i needed to ask the question
okay
are there any other questions
then i shall ask the senior governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you
thank you chair
i will now start the vote i have amended
the recommendation to say to agree the
amended recommendation 2.1 as detailed
in report bc 2122 i'll start the vote
now for you
so if you scroll down to the blue line
on your agenda
to cast your vote
counselor take your vote please oh wow
and council newman
chair that is carried
thank you
thank you members
that brings us to the end
our council meeting
oh sorry
cancer appointments i do beg your pardon
counselor
councillors please could you refer to
the table papers which contain the
details of the appointments that need to
be approved could i have a proposal
thank you councillor alfie could i have
a second
thank you councillor plum
i will now ask the senior government's
office to conduct the electronic vote
i missed that one
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on your app
okay
counselor may i have your vote please
the counsellor's appointments is that um
counselor barrett and kenzler sean
dawson is that what we refer to
what are these
i'm sorry
i didn't even realize that was anywhere
here i must have missed it yes i'll
certainly
uh support that thank you
i take your vote is full
counselor newman full
chair
that is 18 votes for and one abstention
that builds carriage
that now brings us to the end of the
meeting
uh which i apologize and
the date of the next meeting will be
tuesday the 25th of january 2022
at 5 30
so i trust you'll all be in attendance
thank you
it's funny
you